overdosed on fentanyl which i didn't
know what that was but apparently it's
like extra heroin it's what killed
prince
not prince philip the the artist
formerly known as prince
[Music]
hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me chris turner
and me alice wynn and a special guest
clara hi clara hi clara's obsessed with
that privacy
is it annoying that in amer in america
well we pronounce the name clara clara
but you say it
clara i say clara yeah no i don't find
it
i don't find it annoying i honestly
don't know how to pronounce your name
and we've been friends for quite a while
and i just kind of
i just like muddle through every time i
have to say your name i think whatever
is appropriate
for your accent is appropriate so the
background on this is that i have two
accents
and when i speak to clara usually i
speak in an american accent
and so she is putting up with my
fraudulent british accent
right now and i'm actually from scotland
uh so welcome clara it's very nice to
have you here
um we have clara on because obviously
the biggest news story this week was the
death of the uh the queens
a bit on the side prince philip and
clara is a world expert on prince philip
so that's why she's she's here she's not
it's a lie
it's a lie prince philip by way of the
queen yeah you know all about the queen
have you seen the crown
saw the crown yes i never watched it i i
found it tedious
it is quite boring yeah no i mean mostly
i'm just up on
the recent scandal the recent scandal
you mean the megan knuckle stuff
about the queen oh no clara you're so
full of [ __ ]
go on what's the recent queen scandal
just that the queen has been
fondling the balls of all of the humans
what clara so clara knows i don't read
the news and therefore
does this awful thing where she
purposefully
tells me like quite quite believable
breaking news things and she'll often
like
mock up magazine covers
with her false news it's not that i'm
making it up it's just that i'm
bringing it foreseeing it i'm
manifesting it and the queen fondling
so now prince philip has sadly passed
away she's gonna
fully unleash yeah her predatory
tendencies
the problem is that when clara tells me
this and then chris backs her
up it's actually quite hard for me to
not believe it
well it's true yeah the queen is a perv
it's what you're saying yeah i think
that's true it is true
yeah it's not that she's a perv it's
that she's been taking advantage of her
situation and grooming
these human who she casts based on
how they look so she's uh harvey
weinstein that's what you're saying yeah
she calls them into her office and she
office the queen has an office i love it
takes them under her wing to like show
them the ropes and then
yeah sexually assaults them well that's
a pretty
uh hefty accusation you're making
towards her royal majesty
yeah you heard it here first no wonder
megan and harry wanted to get out
dirty bird before we um get on to actual
news stuff we've had a lovely week
yesterday we did some some rare outdoor
adventuring we went to
the black canyon of gunnison national
park
it's a big old canyon it's a big old
canyon it's massive isn't it but we
spent most of the time there
um so there was a rock there called
muscovite right mica which is actually
it's a it's a mineral not a rock
and so we just and you can peel it apart
so we kind of just sat
in a corner staring at our lap you said
it looked to anyone
watching on that we were you know dull
children on our phones
except we weren't on our phones we were
playing with muscovite micah
your brother was there and he he trotted
off he got quickly bored and went for a
walk
yeah we then went for a walk down a
rocky scree and coming up it was some
professional hikers i don't know about
if that's a thing professionally
they were professional they had like
some solar charging packs for their
phones
yeah and shoes just for hiking and they
warned us that it was a
bad way down they said it's a gnarly
descent gnarly descent
yeah it's a gnarly gnarly descent and
you fell
i fell i didn't like that trip i thought
it was not worth
the drive it was a three-hour drive it
was a three-hour drive we made chloride
you made me drive and i think that
nature
is majestic but i also don't care that
much
that's kind of how i feel somewhat like
my favorite walks are the ones with a
pub
at the end chris kept being like this is
just like vr but vr is better
well yeah because in vr you can't
actually fall to your death into a
rocket
i just think neither of you have any
sense of the sublime all right alice
tell us about the sublime ah you don't
want me to tell you the sublime will
take forever
give me a one minute recap
well the sublime in literary terms
refers to a specific
feeling that the romantic poets describe
a lot
in the uh late 18th early 19th century
and it is
a kind of feeling of all mixed with
terror
the best example of it is you're
standing at the bottom of a mountain and
you look up and the top of the mountain
is obscured by clouds so there is no way
of knowing how tall the mountain is
it could go on forever and ever and ever
and imagine that in vr
be so good because there'd be a zombie
behind you and you blow its face off
so we also watched schindler's list not
at the same time
no not on the camera three interviews in
a three-hour movie that's very
depressing it was the first time i'd
watched it it's
really good it's very good it's i mean i
i'd seen it before but i've forgotten
how good it was
um and clara made us watch it she was
like i think this is a really
really like fun evening activity for us
and it was i think it's kind of
craftsmanship at its finest it was very
big it was and it's
all in black and white if you haven't
seen it it's all in black and white
because uh
steven spielberg wanted it to be
timeless and my brother kept going on
about the fact that he made it
six months before he made jurassic park
yeah it came out the same year as george
which is an
insane like blockbuster year for a
director to be like schindler's list and
jurassic park
the production studio said to spielberg
you have to you can make this we'll give
you money but you have to make jurassic
park first because after you've made
this i don't think you'll want to make a
film about dinosaurs
so clara clara and i have been watching
the bbc pride and prejudice um
which clara was disorienting just to
clarify the british broadcasting
corporation chris come on
some pornographic twist on the jane
austen classic and
um and clara clara was she hasn't seen
it
and you were disoriented by how everyone
is quite plain in that in that
version of it compared to the kira
knightly version yeah
i'm starved for like the more anorexic
chiseled kind of because they didn't
have been well nourished back then
no they would have been they would have
been fine it was it was attractive to be
a bit plump
yes but as you point out alice
you think or it is the bbc version
is more um true to the
intent to the book yes yeah and the
meaning of the book i think but anyway
the reason i bring it up is that there's
this scene in pride and prejudice
where um mr darcy proposes to elizabeth
but in this like incredibly insulting
way where he's like
uh it disgusts me that i'm attracted to
you and like your whole family is
embarrassing and
despite all of this i still kind of
fancy you and i don't know what to do
about it
and while we were watching that clara
was like oh um
there's an homage to this scene and
shouldn't his list and i was like no
there isn't and obviously because clara
lies to me about everything all the time
i was like convinced this was not so but
in fact the kind
that kind of there is and in fact
i listened to ray fines talking about
this scene many years later and he was
like it's about a man
struggling with his attraction explain
the context of the scene
so helen hirsch is
the attractive jewish maid that ray
finds this also miss honey for matilda
also miss honey for matilda also natasha
the [ __ ]
girlfriend in um british i thought you
said she was thin
she's that girl no she's not that girl
she's the one who's um she looks like
that girl
darcy yes oh oh oh okay right get back
on track what am i talking about
right i just want to join in saying
helen
uh she's his maid he plays eamon good
the bloodthirsty nazi
um he goes down into the basement where
she is taking a bath
like but she's standing up taut dripping
wet
nipples wearing like a gown
wearing a sheath so what's that
it's like like a slip yeah okay i
thought that was like a
religious thing where you said sheath i
thought oh that's a name i didn't
realize
yeah so he goes to talk to her and he's
like you know if there's ever anything
you need
i just think you're the best maid and
uh i mean is this the face of a rat we
could just
have sex right now and it would be
totally but then he
realized what he's realizes what he's
saying and uh beats the [ __ ] out of her
which is kind of like
mr mr darcy and elizabeth a man
struggling with his attraction
because of a prejudice
yeah it's actually almost identical
really as scenes go is that what
raf science said in his interview yeah
he was like i was mr darcy
no but it's the same kind of
subtext i guess so pride and prejudice
is a little more
sympathetic towards mr darcy yeah mainly
because he doesn't go and then
shoot people also do you remember my
idea
what was your idea oh yeah this was
great it's a remake of pride and
prejudice
but they're germans and they live right
next to auschwitz but while the war is
going on and they're
gassing everybody they're just involved
in their own little like
romance this came up because as we were
watching more pride and prejudice
after we'd watched in this list i was
like this all seems really
stupid suddenly because the holocaust
happened
and clara was like oh i've now got a
script idea yes
mr darcy is a proud nazi i don't think
this would get made i think i don't
think this will get greenlit
i don't know the executives are like i
love the juxtaposition
i feel like we should stress that clara
here is jewish and we are not
oh yeah good good good looking out yeah
just because you know
our listeners might not know but the
viewers do we're very blonde hair blue
eyed
so gotta make sure we uh we clarify that
it would be weird if every guest we got
on we were like and they're jewish
um that's the policy we only booked
jewish guests
um but um chris what do you think of
clara's screenplay idea i think it's
banging i think you should do it
do it and then you know in a year and a
half check back in and everyone will buy
buy tickets to go and see it
right datsy and nazis boom let's talk
about the news
okay uh it feels inappropriate to start
by going boom because prince philip
has died he he died he died uh
very sad that anyone dies and i always
feel you know
that it's it's most tasteful not to make
jokes about someone who's died last
night i did make a joke about it did you
i was doing a show
and i i i was introduced they go your
headline is an amazing rapper please
welcome chris turner and i said hello uh
yes i do usually rap but
i have chat with the producers and
tonight uh they've said that i can use
my 10 minute set
for 10 minutes of silence
[Laughter]
it got a big laugh made me think they
were very disrespectful
they were all canadian so he's there
he's there king too
is he i don't know the queen's that
queen all right it
isn't it annoying that he never got to
be a king he was always a prince like a
99 year old prince
well it is it's a kind of form of sexism
isn't it because it's it's
the idea that if he were king then that
would mean he was more like kings are
inherently more powerful than queens
in many card games correct um but not in
chess
that is also true yes um although you
have to catch the king to win if you
catch the queen it's like yeah [ __ ] her
we can carry on without her
it's kind of a big deal if you get
someone's queen yeah but you can turn
pawns into queens so you can always get
a new queen
but that takes a lot of yeah it's pretty
hard
to get that good word
he's he's uh passed away and apparently
the bbc has gotten
like quite excited about this excited
the wrong word just
the coverage so there'll be eight days
of national mourning which is a lot
um and the bbc have just been spewing
out
show after show about prince philip
cancelling anything that's fun
you know if the bake off was on that
would have been cancelled um
all the music on the radio is like
military naval music
i mean on classical music i'm not saying
that like the new ed sheeran song
military march version although that
would improve his songs immensely
um yeah i mean he was very old he was 99
yeah so i mean yeah all the jerks going
around for the last six months where
he's already dead right all the photos
of him
he did he looked terrible he didn't look
super on top of it
no but you know prior to that like 2016
he drove the obamas when they came the
uk drove them around
didn't crash into anyone two years ago
crashing into people
that sounds really scary i don't know
that i would
want prince philip to drive you around
in 2019 no
uh dmx died dmx did die i don't know is
that that sounds like
a type of drug that is the the rap name
of earl williams
okay simmons l simmons yes i'm getting
it wrong i apologized
gosh i've really blown my rap
credibility there is he
um well was he young 50.
that's quite young yeah died of a heart
attack from a drug overdose
that's sad yes deathly weak
yeah yeah i mean lots of other people
have died but just not
important we don't know their names yeah
it's uh
i did see a good tweet from maybe four
years ago which someone had retweeted
saying if i was banksy when prince
philip died i would immediately stop
making artwork just to make everyone
wonder
pretty fancy yes r.i.p prince phil and
dmx i met prince philip
um and he didn't say hello to me because
it was me along with 50 other people
getting their duke of edinburgh gold
award
but he did say hi to my mum because
you know she had got her duke on broad
when she was younger and he said
is anyone here got a parent who has a
drug veteran award
and she went yes and he walks over to
her and he goes oh very good what did
you do for your expedition she said i
did horseback riding
and then he did uh a j i can't remember
the joke but it made her laugh a lot
um there were horses foreigners
um and then then moved on but he's
charming and nice
in that one interaction yeah well that
means he's probably all right then
yeah yeah one nice thing if i like him
the one time i meet him then he's
probably all right all the time yeah
one thing as a comedian um people always
ask you they're like
oh is this person really nice most the
time they are
most people are nice i have a general
rule about
name dropping which is that you
shouldn't name drop unless you have a
story attached
like you can't just be like oh i saw
sarah jessica parker once in a
supermarket that's not a story
you shouldn't really name drop at all
unless you're
with close friends that's very wise
but then how will you make strangers
impressed that's also very very wise
i don't think it's impressive to really
name drop that's why you only do it with
people that won't
you know you're you're sharing in the
fun of
you know having clara is much more
tasteful than either of us
yeah i love name dropping yeah i think
it's my favorite thing i i name drop
when it can be funny
right like alice always says that all my
stories make me the hero yeah
but i had a couple of my name drop
stories i'm sorry darling your
prince phillips story that you just told
us was not a funny story
i was just saying i have a personal
connection with someone who's died have
some respect
wench what is what is this award the
duke of edinburgh award yes what is it
in the 1950s so it's
um it's to get young people helping in
the community
so there's bronze silver and gold and
you get them over periods of like 6 12
and 18 months
and you have to do three months
charitable service three months learning
a skill
three months learning it's quite intense
it is quite a lot and then you do a hike
at the end of it
an expedition most people will hike it
some people
like my mom for some reason who
apparently was well off as a child got
to do on horses
uh there's people doing kayaks as well
like oh do you want to hike 50 miles or
row 50 of course want to row 50 miles we
didn't get to do that sweet
uh were proper hardcore hikers um and so
i did bronze silver and gold
and it was i really enjoyed it i worked
in a charity shop in wales and learned a
bit of welsh
i learned guitar as one of my skills i
ended up hiking for five days over
mountains with a bunch of friends
it was really good is this sort of the
equivalent of the boy scouts or do you
have boy scouts
i did it while in the boy scouts oh you
have boy scouts over there so i also at
the same time
achieved my queen scout award which you
could do in tandem so i
got yeah the queen and the prince you
you peaked
i picked i did i did that was the
highlight in my life i want i want to do
my name drop story
okay sorry yes this is just i was doing
a gig at like a private members club
um and they said okay the room's gonna
we have to finish the gig at 11 pm
because then the room opens to all the
members
and so i finished it bang on 11 and as
soon as i finished people were clapping
um people kind of get up and i'm like oh
they're going to come over and say hi
just that moment a door opens behind me
all the other members come in the first
person front of the line noel fielding
a much more famous comedian than me and
so people who just stood up just
immediately went over to him just be
like oh no fielding you're amazing like
hey
you just did a comedy show he hasn't
even done a joke and you want to go and
say hi
felt too weird to go over and say hi and
be like i was a comedian i just did a
show in there and you stole my thunder
hello please
i think when jerry seinfeld bumped some
comedians off because he was trying for
like trying out new material and the
comedian goes on everyone's like hey
that's the second time in a week you
bought me from a show and jerry sample
went
get over it
great response grow up yeah
be funnier um so prince philip dmx
rip may you jam to x gonna give it to
you
uh beyond the pearly gates news story
we're going to move all the way to sri
lanka which i'm sure prince philip has
been
um and said some tasteless things a sri
lankan beauty
pageant ended in turmoil because
the 2019 sri lankan mrs world winner
no mrs world decided that the winner of
the 2021
mrs world did not deserve the crown
because she was divorced
and so she put the crown was put on the
winner's head and she then walked over
to the winner
took it off her which took a long time
because it was tangled in her hair yeah
and then put it on
the runner-up the crowd erupted to cheer
and start chanting yeah well the real
winner walks off stage crying
and the person who moved the crown goes
she's a divorcee
she doesn't deserve to win um and then
the contest
uh had to issue a statement saying no
she's not divorced she's
a legitimate winner so she wasn't it was
all
a falsehood she's not even divorced no
she's separated but they weren't
divorced
i see so the issue is not whether or not
a divorcee can
win mrs world the issue was that she was
not in fact divorced yeah she wasn't
divorced
but she was in hospital for head
injuries and if you read the new story
it describes it as a brawl
it's literally like the reverse crowning
of a pope
it's just so lightly she just takes the
crown off just very lightly gets tangled
and yeah she's been arrested for like
assault and harm
wow well it's not a super gracious
way to behave is it don't take a crown
off another woman's head
when she's just one when the highlight
of her it's very it's very
kanye and taylor isn't it at the ground
yes it is
is it also expressly prohibited the
rules say you cannot be divorced
if you want to be mrs world because then
obviously you've sullied your missus
i see yes in the same way that you can't
ever have been pregnant if you want to
be miss
anything just you know it's the way it
is alice i'm sorry
it is the way it is you know well that
that happened a few years ago too didn't
it
when steve harvey announced miss
universe or something
and it was the wrong one and he took the
crown off her head in real time oh
am i getting this right i don't know but
we'll trust you yeah and the queen was
there
with her yeoman boyfriend he's just
fondling him
it's very moonlight and la la land
doesn't it all of this i mean it just
it is there's a specific kind of sadness
that you get for someone
who's got a crown on their head having
it removed in front of people it's just
sad
it's very yeah it's shamey
shaming exactly so napoleon crowned
himself
he took the crown from the pope's hands
and put it on his own head because the
pope was supposed to crown you
and he just took it out of the pope's
hands and um
he did this because he wanted to be like
i am making myself emperor right
i'm not getting my emperor ship from the
pope uh
but the pr on it was pretty bad because
everyone was like oh
tacky napoleon like grabs the crowd out
of the pope's hands
but apparently like he had arranged this
with the pope beforehand like the pope
wasn't taking
away he's surprising the pope no
was that a good poet or a bad poet i
don't remember what kind of pope he was
pope or the anti-pope it was a big deal
because that's much earlier chris i'm
sorry well maybe people don't know
there was a time there was a big old
schism where there were two popes they
had
the pope and then the pope in avignon
right is that right i'm trying to
remember when around that would have
been but i think it must have been the
11th or 1200s oh wow
and so you had to decide which pope you
supported
who was the proper pope exactly very
complicated stuff
but uh it was still a big deal when
napoleon got the pope in because
the um the french revolution had been
highly anti-religious so for instance
um notre dame cathedral was converted
into a temple of reason
and they got rid of all religious
trappings and so
the whole country had been like very
anti the pope for ages and then napoleon
kind of like
invites religion back into the country
by having the pope at his
coronation not all bad well
yeah i mean he did some good stuff
napoleon
such as uh he invited the jews back to
france
and he standardized education and he
created a legal code
and um he believed in meritocracy and
i mean yeah he had some some good stuff
i mean he was also you know a pretty
bloodthirsty dictator but yeah how long
did he reign
well let's see he he seized he there was
a coup
in 1799 and he seized control of the
directory which had been this kind of
like inefficient
revolutionary government and then
i don't know when he became emperor by
uh the battle of waterloo when he was
finally defeated is in 1815.
so it's not that long and then there's
all that elba business
elba was before so helena afterwards
yeah so
uh there's a bad i can't remember what
gets him sent to elba i think it's
1814-ish
he gets sent to elba by the way does
great stuff for elba
like helps that government like
reorganizes it
he's only there for like a matter of
months just want to plug in with saint
helena
i learned a couple of lines from the
saint helena national anthem
please tell us then um because their
official one is god save the queen but
they had an unofficial one written by a
dj who'd never visited saint helena but
had seen a postcard and felt an affinity
with it
um so the lines are
diamonds they are pretty so is your
fancy cars but saint helena island is
much prettier by far
and it goes on to say how if there was a
heaven god would make it saint helena
that's lovely but i just
so is your fancy cars yes so people um
saints people in saint helena uh that's
the dialect they speak
okay all right uh very well i accept it
yes so elba for a while and then he
escapes which by the way the english
like
like castle ray was like i don't think
elba is far enough away
because he's napoleon he's going to
escape and everyone else is like it'll
be fine
and then obviously he has gates then
there's 100 days
and then the battle of waterloo where he
is finally defeated and sent to saint
helena where apparently he was very
close friends with a little girl
oh no one else speak to him he's very
lonely you do need to clarify that well
he wasn't like creeping on him okay good
that's why i wanted to check because we
spoke about matt gates last week
which update on that this week yes um he
obviously didn't know how to use venmo
because there's
his public venmo profile showed him
making payments to uh
joel greenberg who's the person who was
charged with sex trafficking and has now
turned state's evidence and is probably
going to testify against matt gates
uh made him public payments uh using the
nicknames of
several young women that joel greenberg
was known to pay for sex
okay but the question i have is why does
venmo have a social media component
it is honest it doesn't make any sense
so for people who aren't in the us
because i think it's really only in the
u.s that they have venmo venmo is this
bizarre like like
bank account app slash social media app
so you can like go onto your home page
and see
what all of your friends are buying so
it'll be like some kid i knew in high
school
being like to stay cm sushi
yeah also why do you have to put the
reason for payment
i guess because that's kind of useful
right like if people
are sending me an invoice and they just
put you know i see
show i'm like oh just say what it was
because then i can match the payments up
i like it because i can see how petty
people are like there'll be people and
i'm like
yeah i get it if you've been going out
two years you're still you know
like paying people back but then there's
like people that i know and i'm like
hmm why are you charging your girlfriend
for dinner
that feels weird i'm not sure this is
gonna last not naming any names
but i just why why is this a social
media
i don't it doesn't make any sense i
don't like it because i can see
all of my high school friends are like
getting meals with each other
and not inviting and not inviting yeah
that's horrible isn't it i know i get
sucked in
matt gates didn't totally understand the
social media component no
um but yeah napoleon was friends with
the little girl but not in a strange way
no yeah and um we think that there may
have been something like lead in his
paint
he dies pretty shortly after he arrives
and say helene and he wasn't that old i
don't think
napoleon yeah no pull or nap but he
didn't think that would be his end when
he took the crown off the pope
he's probably like i'm gonna be bloody
god no
no i think he probably thought he'd be
all right they he was um
he was on a bit of a winning streak for
a while and then he was defeated
by britain by wellington
why doesn't wellington have a column
nelson gets one but not well right and
the thing is trafalgar doesn't seem like
as important a battle as well
now i think wellington um i wonder
whether other
countries think that wellington's as
important as britain does so well the
duke of wellington
we think of as being responsible for
defeating napoleon but uh i don't think
actually
britain had a very large like had many
men
there like i think that it was a it was
most of the um people who were killed
were not
like there was a lot of austrians and i
don't know abba wrote the song waterloo
is why
why was sweden involved i don't know
um it's a metaphor for what for
surrendering to love
ah i've never watched um whatever the
film's called
so i is do they explain that because i
know all the songs
all other songs are then used in the
film to do different things right phil
muller yeah
like the second one because explain the
discard
okay cool pierce brosnan's in it singing
badly and we watched we watched him this
week we golden i didn't we
did yeah that was good poor clara's
walked straight into our james bond
marathon and
has been an unwilling participant i know
i'm just such a
bummer just negging everything we do
yeah you're very
very unpleasant to be around
um talking about uh unpleasant things
the
uh american intelligence agencies
have released their uh kind of what does
it mean every four years is there a word
like biannual's two years
like quad quadrant quadranium
every four years they release a report
about what they think is going to happen
in the world
like 10 years 20 years from now can i
guess we're all going to get richer and
prettier and younger
oh maybe us but uh the world in general
uh not not going well they are so
basically i think in
maybe eight years ago they did a whole
thing about how um
predicting a massive pandemic in 2023
that would ruin everything
they predicted in 20 2004 2008 they
predicted
uh the rise of an islamic caliphate out
of the
war in iraq the thing is it doesn't it's
not very useful to talk about all the
predictions they got right like
yeah you wouldn't hear about the
predictions their predictions are pretty
broad so what they've said is
climate change is going to [ __ ] everyone
right um there's
uh anti-democratic sentiments are going
to get worse and worse far-right
terrorism is going to be a real problem
um it was just very very depressing it's
all like
hey you know we have all these um
democratic states at the moment
in 20 years a lot of them will not be
democratic anymore
which seems to be a thing that's
happening you know
yeah when we went to that human rights
conference in 2016 which we love to
bring up
that's your equivalent of name dropping
i know i love it but the thing is
that uh the theme was democracy and like
the fall of democracy and everyone was
freaking out about democracy like
collapsing around the world i wasn't
really paying attention to any of that i
was just like you just
get a rap for gary kasparov who is gary
kasparov chess master first
first chess player beaten by a computer
what a sad
thing i know right that's what you're
famous for yeah and i wasn't he was
wearing a mustard yellow jacket and i
wasn't allowed to introduce him on stage
with the joke
why does gary kasparov wear that jacket
because he doesn't like deep blue
because deep blue is in here with the
ibm supercomputer that beat him who
would have got a big laugh
would have got a big laugh was it in
norway that i did a joke about
that conversation a joke about you and
someone turned to you and was like
yeah so chris made some kind of joke
about how i was ugly and then
the person i was sitting at the table
with just turned to me and was like
you're not
and i was like i know it's a joke they
were like they were they
they liked you less afterwards he
genuinely thinks europeans
they were just like wow it's terrible to
be married to someone who doesn't love
you
i believe he would say that in public i
got quite a lot of sympathy actually
from people being like this poor woman
married to this man who just thinks
she's a troll
the rates are on stage it's the only
time i can speak that's my therapy
my wife doesn't love her she's a troll
troll the word troll has been
um kind of devalued yeah
because describing someone as a troll
it's very funny yeah it's a good one
so things not looking good world's gonna
end but you know what's new in other
news in
bessemer which is in alabama um
an amazon warehouse decided to try and
unionize
and everyone was very excited and joe
biden got behind it and bernie sanders
got behind it
and then they've had a vote and they
have not unionized why didn't they
unionize
because uh workers would argue that
amazon have been gaslighting their
workers
so there was a a poster from a couple of
years ago that was delta or united
trying to not let their workers unionize
saying you need the average union jews
are 400
with that you could buy a ps4 and some
games why join a union
um and so i think i was going to be
doing that saying hey
you already get paid 15 an hour which um
is accurate it's true um they the
minimum wage is decent
actually the best my warehouse is is
like seven and a half dollars an hour so
they
you know and the benefits but i think
the problems are like
workers get annoyed with the off task
tracking so whenever you're not doing
your work in the amazon warehouse there
is a computer tracking you
yeah and if you do too many hours off
task which they don't tell you how many
because then obviously you'd push up
that limit
because why wouldn't you take more break
like no one likes working right
right um they they just come and fire
you they're like
hey two minutes out and this one was
talking how like these warehouses are
huge if i want to go to the bathroom
it's a 10 minute walk
it's like so if i do that i don't want
to do it when i'm working because i
might get fired and i need this job
but if i do my break that's 20 minutes
of my break gone
right and she's like it's even worse if
you're working on the top floor you have
to go all these flights of stairs and
like that adds loads of time um yeah oh
and things like
essentially people are accused of union
busting and saying look
people should have a right to vote on a
union without your influence do you
remember that episode in the office
when the warehouse workers want to
unionize
and like the it's funny because the the
prevailing narrative of the office is
like
lol no and like michael is like yeah
that's a good idea for a second and then
everyone's like michael what are you
doing they can't unionize then
well jan is like what
he let's he's like we should all
unionize because they like him more
right when he yes says they should but
it feels like the office
as a as a show is being like
oh it'd be bad if these workers unionize
really i don't know maybe i'm
misinterpreting it
i think it depends on your personal
politics alice obviously went down to
bessemer to help amazon smash the union
drive
no but i think americans are quite
freaked out by unions
yeah yeah which in the uk it's a it's
just a part of thing i mean i was
asked when i worked at tesco they were
like oh do you want to join the union
and i said what does it do for me and
they said this and i said cool
how much does it cost i said this and i
said okay i only work this many hours a
week that's not worth it for me
but i'm a member of equity the acting
and the entertainment union because
well that's my job so that does make
sense yeah i lost my sag card
why what happened nobody hired me
you lose it when that happens for people
who are not familiar that's the screen
actors guild card
not like a droopy union are you in the
writer's guild
yes okay and what are the perks of being
in the writers guild um
are you worried if you tell us the perks
they'll they'll find no it's great
they send you lots of emails and they
protect you
you get paid like they set pay rates
right that's right do they
give you health insurance yes
yes that's a good benefit that's a
pretty great benefit yeah do
uh they don't give me health insurance
but i assume that they give some people
health insurance
they just look at the like no you're
fine don't worry we'll give it to this
guy
you seem healthy joe yeah no i think if
you're
fancier
there's no one fancier than you you're
highly glamorous thank you so much
um yeah lost my side card very sad
well you know who else isn't glamorous
who khloe kardashian
oh yes okay i do know about this because
i tend to know about only the
unimportant bits of things the instagram
even though this picture
was not on instagram and it's not
allowed to say khloe kardashian i'm sure
you know about this
there was a picture put up of her that
was an unflattering picture
where she looked like a normal person
she looked yeah yeah they're like it's
an unflattering photo like oh no you
just look like
a friend posting a bikini photo right
and
so apparently her lawyers slash agents
slash you know people were just like
this must be erased from the internet
yeah
it must be a very stressful
life to have to kind of police
every i mean i hate every picture that's
taken of me i can't imagine trying to
eradicate all bad pictures of me
i asked flowers usually i filmed this in
120 frames per second she was like no
that's four times as many as 30 frames
per second
so this way there are a few isn't it
weird when you think about it movies
are just pictures really it's just it's
just a sequence of pictures yeah i mean
you've got those little books where you
flip through them and
it moves it's smiling basically and he
moves yeah that's how that's how we're
gonna raise our kids no movies just
flips
flip plugs yeah have you seen that new
marvel film no have you seen a man
falling down a hole
he falls down and you could make him
fall back
um yeah no i think it must be an awful
way to be famous to be honest and think
how freaked out they must be about aging
yes i mean i think we've talked about
this well chris and i certainly have i
think the ideal amount of famous is
john williams because you're obsessed
with him
yes when he dies i have sex with john
williams
i don't want to have sex with him i just
i just want to be able to have sex
with him the response to prince philip's
death you think would be merited if it
was the response to john william's death
correct like every radio station can
only play john williams for eight days
i think that would be the least they
could do because there's so much of his
he's the modern mozart he's the most
important composer of our time so he
composed the music for schindler's list
and when steven spielberg showed in the
film and asked him to compose it he said
you need a better composer than me to
compose the music of this film and
steven spielberg said i know but they're
all dead
which seems like a zing but it's not
it's steven spielberg's saying no
you are the greatest living musician but
i i mean i actually think he
you know he rivals a lot of you know the
classic composers
anyway the point is he's a really nice
and famous right because
i don't think he he probably doesn't get
recognized more than a couple times a
week
like i don't think he's getting mobbed
at the supermarket but
he like if he were to go to i mean he's
really [ __ ] old
well i'm so worried about him anyway um
he's gonna
he's made it through covered he must be
vaccinated by now yeah but
um when he goes to a party right he
you know anyone who know people people
who recognize his name
love him and people who don't recognize
his name like don't you know what i mean
there's not very many people who are
going to meet him and be like oh i don't
really respect your work
john williams fat
disgusting picture of john williams
science
cellulite on john williams's thigh
unedited john williams do you think if
he introduced himself if he goes john
williams someone goes sorry who
he just goes like just like hums a bit
of one of his songs
it'd be a great way to introduce
yourself i'm sure he's terribly humble
now on to uh breaking news more like
record-breaking news do you know the
statue of christ the redeemer in rio on
sugarloaf mountain
yes big old statue in it yeah it's not
the biggest one in brazil anymore
because
some place that is not real i was going
to say some shitty little backwater and
i
did not do any research of this is
building a taller christ the
christ statue and it's gonna have a
viewing platform in christ's chest
not in his head for some reason uh where
you can look out over the surrounding
farmland
so it's it's whack compared to christ
the redeemer
on a mountain i think it's kind of cool
i like i like ambitious building
projects
yeah it just feels like you know build
another type of thing
why are you making it like we have the
famous jesus statue it's the third
biggest one in the world christ the
redeemer
right the the other ones in poland one's
in indonesia
and they are um one of them is maybe
like
five centimeters taller than the other
one so you know that one was built
second right that's that's poland going
hey look at our big statue and then
indonesia going oh you think it was big
five centimeters more it does seem petty
i'll admit to like
just be like we want to build the same
statue just slightly bigger why make it
jesus why not just be like look we love
jesus make it a big virgin mary
yeah yeah i mean jesus is quite
important in fairness it shows mary
yeah fair there are bigger statues in
the world that
are of mary mary and the buddha i think
are the ones that they make big statues
of
aren't there some quite large like
ex-soviet statues
like big stalin's like big horses yeah
i mean i imagine they'd be taken down
wouldn't they yeah i wonder if they all
live in these kind of statue graveyards
that's because you've been watching
james bond yeah there's a soviet statue
graveyard i just think so
that was cool it was very very it was a
good place for like a
america's next top model pro like
mission um there was an episode of
america's next top model
in like 2010 or something like the last
season
maybe a little bit later where the
models had to
walk down a building i remember this
while yeah they're like abseiling down a
skyscraper
smoldering yeah and it's interesting
that's hard because if you are taking a
photograph of someone who's facing the
floor
their face looks different right because
it kind of gravity pulls their face away
from their skull yeah no they all looked
like
disgusting freaks
so there we go i guess chloe kardashian
should be grateful she wasn't walking
down the building when they took that
photo that show was so ridiculous
because tyra banks was obviously it was
a reality tv show so she wanted them to
do absurd things
so she'd do things like be like okay now
you're going to pose just covered in
bees
and if a girl was like but i don't want
to pose covered in bees tyler would be
like are you a model or not
models have to do things that they don't
want to do
are you serious about this job and these
like 19 year old
girls from like impoverished backgrounds
are like yes yes
i am serious you know it's like
incredibly exploitative
yeah real models have to be able to do
the heimlich maneuver
we now come to the segment of the show
where traditionally alice would tell us
something about uh you know something
interesting that she knows well
but you guys have had a bloody balling
week and you've been keeping me filled
in
the only reason clara agreed to come on
the show was because we said we could
let talk about demi lovato about demi
lovato
yes okay sammy lovato clara likes
watching
sort of celebrity documentaries yeah how
do you start off by explaining
who owner demi lovato it's not actually
clear we don't know
okay she's very famous we know her name
she's half a normal lovato we know
yeah that very good we know she's famous
and now because of this documentary
dancing with the devil which is also
incidentally the title of her upcoming
single or upcoming album what a surprise
uh we know that she uh
struggled with a bad addiction and uh
overdose she she was a disney style
right so she and like selena gomez were
kind of contemporaries
she was a child star yeah yeah and then
as i mean disney has some answering to
do because all of their child stars get
so [ __ ] up and i was talking to you
about this and i was like
the harry potter crew are fine i mean
they're not fine yeah they were a bit
[ __ ] up during it right daniel
radcliffe wasn't our key
they're so much better off than the
disney stars though the disney stars
have a really hard time rupert grin
has a charmed life because like emma
watson has you know
is a pretty woman and so she has to deal
with all that daniel radcliffe was harry
potter so he has to deal with every role
he has being less than that rupert
grinch's just like
all right mate i've got a lot of money
he has a
i think he has an ice cream truck i
auditioned i auditioned for
i love the idea from having an ice cream
truck i auditioned for a film
called thunder pants which he was in i
remember that film um
and it's about someone who can fart a
lot right yeah it's like that that's the
type of [ __ ] he can do
yeah he is having a great time but i but
i maintain i think that whatever disney
does to their child stars is clearly
worse than what the harry potter kind of
system was doing to their child stance
fair enough anyway so demi lovato
uh tell tell what you know when she was
18
she had a drug problem or something she
was doing
coke and xanax and then her team forced
her to be sober for six years
uh and she felt very controlled and so
she
just had like an eating disorder and she
had a raging eating disorder and then
she
relapsed and went straight to smoking
heroin right that was her first point of
call
yeah no first she had like a glass of
wine okay
yeah and then people say that is a
gateway yes
and then she started smoking heroin um
overdosed on fentanyl which i didn't
know what that was but apparently it's
like extra heroin
it's what killed prince not prince
philip the the artist formerly known as
prince
huh um anyway
i feel like i just really relate to this
because of my crippling marijuana
addiction
um right well okay so for instance in
the show
yeah she's like in the documentary she's
like i'm now
sober and yes yet she's
she's kind of sober she does weed and
drinking yeah which are both legal
in many places and so i can see what
happens it could work out but i do think
she's not out of the
drug mindset because in her new house
she has built
a room that she calls her shroom room
which is designed she grows delicious
little
culinary fungi for her cooking ishitaki
it's designed to be perfect to trip on
shrooms which doesn't seem like you're
really like
kind of buying into the soba lifestyle
fully here's the thing
being sober sucks it's boring and stupid
and like i relate because i feel like
the older i get 26.
so very old um nobody wants to like
do drugs or be irresponsible anymore
like for instance both of you are sober
very boring and um i should clarify
i'm not sober i just well you are right
now
yeah no not drunk while recording i'm
not terribly unprofessional that's the
thing in the uk
the phrase i'm sober does not mean i
don't
do drugs or drinks it means it means i'm
not drunk right now
which means it's very rare because
everyone in the uk especially in this
national morning
yeah this is an excuse now for people to
get pissed raise a pint and go
let's talk about some of the best things
he said about people who aren't white
right oh my god that was what he did
when i was growing when i was like seven
the newspapers would be like would
literally publish things prince philip
went to
djibouti uh he greet the prime minister
saying aren't you a funny little man
yeah he's very rude and it was just it
was like
i remember how megan and harry had to
like specify when they were there when
someone in the family asked you know how
do you think it was a baby do you think
it was philip no they
said it was
and they really could have thrown andrew
under the bus because really right if
you're if you're a pedophile it doesn't
really matter if you're a racist as well
does it
doesn't know it's not like oh well he's
not that bad because at least he
believes in equality he's not a racist
pedophile yeah
exactly um no yeah and we all assumed it
was philip but then harry was like it
wasn't philip and everyone was like well
who else
and that's the thing is that it's just
such a ver acknowledgement that it's the
kind of thing he would say
absolutely is um wait okay hang on so go
on so being being
sober is incredibly boring and stupid
and you hate it and every moment of it
is pain yes
i just feel like i have a lot of
ambition but then there's also
this part of me that wants to like die
choking on my own
vomit and and you can't really reconcile
you're 26 so you need to do that
yeah i need to do it right now yeah i
know yeah um
i said to my mother a while ago like
maybe last year
she like didn't want to talk she was on
her phone and i was like you know when i
die tragically young you're going to
really regret not talking to me
right now instead of you know being on
your phone and she went
it's too late for you to die tragically
young yes
amazing how do you die that regretfully
middle age
yeah okay so you you regret you you
sorry
you relate to demi lovato's kind of
struggles because you understand like
her
her desire to kind of not really be in
her own head
is that what it is i don't know i mean i
also
hate marijuana and i want to have it um
yeah
criminalized all the states are
decriminalizing it
yeah but clara thinks it should be an
executable offense because i thought
i'm waging a one-woman ward to have it
criminalized it's you
and then just all the over 50
republicans it's a scourge of the
streets although i don't want it to be
you know i don't want people to be
imprisoned for it i guess but i just
think that we need to take it out of the
hands of children because it's so
dangerous but i'll just
ingest all of it myself to save them
from the horrible so if you smuggle the
weeds then the children will smoke the
weed
i just think that i should be allowed to
smoke weed
all the time and not suffer any
consequences
right
um yeah i mean should be
it's not gonna work out and it doesn't
make me happy weed is bad for you
yeah i'm positive i'm not super i've
never been very keen on it i
i um always find it makes me quite
boring
um i had this one experience which was
bizarre which is that i
got very high accidentally before an
improv rehearsal
um and i didn't know that was an imp it
was like a kind of impromptu improv
rehearsal in edinburgh and
um so i walk into the sitting room and
they're like we're doing a rhyming game
and i was like
what and i just kind of excuse myself
because i just couldn't do it and i lay
in bed and i listened to them rhyming
things like you know uh bob
and call on the cop right not hard stuff
but i lay in bed and i was so stoked and
i was just like how are these geniuses
thinking of these rhymes yeah whereas
now living with me you don't need to be
high to think of that
how is he doing this these rhymes are
incredible genius
if you just pronounce things weird i do
pronounce things weird but that's just
because i'm british no but
that's how you make things rhyme you're
just true yeah yeah break it down mix it
up
yeah it was a real eye-opener for me
when i
wrote a pitch deck while high
once and then the producer reached out
to me and was like hey
um i think this is like i don't know i
think it's a little too casual
and i read it over again and it was sort
of like a
it was like a monologue about how i had
been agoraphobic
in middle school and afraid of
pedophiles
and then my homeroom teacher turned out
to be a pedophile
but it was very you know it was like i i
was explaining it to you
in written form i agree that that's not
like a traditional
television show pitch it was for a movie
about a pedophile so it was on topic but
it was a little
it was a little tangential maybe also
maybe that's
yeah can something be tangential and
tangentially
i think it can be so this documentary
about demi lovato i think maybe made you
see yourself more clearly
i just feel like it's obviously really
trashy to be hanging out with your
friends and then running up to the
bathroom and like
secretly smoking heroin and i feel like
i feel like i identify with that
instinct
feeling of shame i should say any edits
in this podcast have
just been because clara has dashed after
the bathroom to smoke heroin
to chase the dragon as we call it in the
uk that's what smoking heroin is i think
they call it that in america
yeah yeah but when we say it it has more
of a weighty
mythical you know story of because you
can chase
the dragon i guess you can only chase it
with heroin that's sweet sweet h
everyone used to be addicted to like
laudanum and opium yeah back in the day
which had a kind of singular charm to it
because it was it was all these
you know poets hanging out in like sort
of
chinese wooden beds smoking opium and
then
you know having a blast in time writing
some banging poetry yeah getting into it
demi lovato's album is really good
because she's been shrooming up in the
shroom room
have you listened to it i haven't have
you i like
dancing with the devil as a sort of car
sing-along casting a long car song yeah
as in like
all the lyrics are about cars you sing
along to it in the car
she was dancing with the devil she was
out of control
she almost made it to heaven it was
closer than you know
ah wow goosebumps not really but i like
to say that whenever someone quotes
lyrics at me
you put your left leg in goosebumps
what do you call that what's that dance
the hokey pokey
yeah hokey cokey in the uk weird we love
cocaine that's why that's what you do
you put your nostril in um is
if we covered demi lovato i think so we
should just wish her well hope that her
recovery goes along
yes she's had a hard time in the media
people have been dicks to her because
she had this terrible eating disorder
and then she like managed to put on some
weight because she needed to
there was a bit in the in the
documentary where they talked about how
for like six years she only ate for her
birthday she'd have watermelon cake that
was incredibly grounded
it was a watermelon that had been iced
to look like a cake
but then when you cut it open it's just
it's a watermelon
it's very depressing it's so depressing
it would drive me to smoking here
and then every time there was a picture
of her you know and she's trying to
recover from this eating disorder
everyone would just be like wow demi
lovato is fat now
yeah i'm sure it did not really help her
disorder particularly
poor demi yeah so hope she's all right
yes we
we wish her well i hope
she's recovered from her eating disorder
etc i also have an eating disorder
which is why i also identify yeah should
i
do heroin
if it's good enough for me look she got
a documentary
she's been on joe rogan i know she did
go on jorgen and that was quite funny
because
there's this bit where she's like my she
was who was it exactly
i also identify with like uh
hiring uh charlatans to tell you what to
do
you are absolutely the kind of person
who would have been
sucked into rasputin's whole spell yeah
absolutely
completely would have bought into it my
reaction to the nexium dock which i'm
sure was many people's reaction was like
i could see myself
what's nixiem becoming this man that
cult that sex cult right that sex
cult and you were like i want to join i
was just like i think that i probably
could have been
okay but so she had so she had hired
like an astrologist or something
no she says that she's working with a
healer
um that isn't trained in any specific
type of healing but that is a healer and
she was talking to joe rogan about this
and she was like my healer told me
oh yes in february that my career was
going to slow down and like she turned
out to be right because she
could predict the future and joe rogan
was like well but in february the
pandemic had started
so everyone knew that yeah she says her
healer predicted kovid
and her healer said your career is going
to slow down but don't worry everyone's
career is going to slow down
um i also love astrologists i have many
of them that i watch on youtube
and they tell me what to do
yes correct and then you tell me the the
knowledge you've gleaned from them and i
sort of am incredibly
uns unsupportive of your belief system
yeah
because i have a hard time with people
who care about horoscopes i remember
being
post a show at the comedy cellar and
telling some people about
you and they were like she sounds great
she sounds awesome do you know her
sign and i was like no and they're like
because she's definitely in and they
said some [ __ ] star sign
and and they they were like they were
like yeah she's oh no she definitely is
and because
you're what are you and i said virgo
like oh my god yeah you guys are perfect
if she's this
and then they went when's your birthday
so told me about then they went oh
is she sure about that and they believed
that you would have lied or
not known your real birthday rather than
the fact that it could all be [ __ ]
and they were wrong
um what are you i am a sagittarius
yeah yeah i don't know what my rising is
right and that's important yes because
actually
my moon yeah your moon no the rising is
important because that's how you
present so actually your real sign
doesn't really matter
seems convenient
what's your yeah um you're born on
tuesday
but i mean i maintain that it's really
it's just so that you can look at a
bunch of lists of characteristics
and be like oh i am
you know frightened of change
one time i talked to a psychic over the
phone
why do you do this to yourself and i
thought at the time i was like blown
away and years later i was like that was
totally brilliant i was like we got on
the phone and i was like i'm
bulimic and she was like yes
you are and i was like she knows
i i've never done anything like that but
i was walking out of the comedy cellar
another night walked past a woman in a
deck chair
on the pavement of the greenwich village
or wherever wherever it was
and um she goes uh astrological readings
i said no thank you she said you have a
unique aura
and i almost stopped turning around and
went
[ __ ] astrologically read me because
what essentially it's just like
verbal blow jobs right yeah don't why go
to a hooker
when you can go to a i don't know if
hook is a
is the term i was talking about people
who play a certain position in rugby
very well very well
um okay right it's the end of the show
we've covered demi lovato yeah we've
covered all the news
um i think it's time for you to wrap
it is up for the wrap of the week news
where alice and clara are going to give
me topics about it
what's that first one going to be oscar
schindler's friendship with eamon
okay yes freestyle off the top of my
mind i'm talking about liam nielsen
and ralph finds there in the camp with
the jews they were like we need to make
friends what are we gonna do
have a drink together in vagal in your
social circle i know this might be
slightly hurtful but don't worry
steven spielberg he can get it the
portrayal of oscar was quite sympathetic
had a little arc emotional a one goal
there yeah
a solution for you but he gets hung
there at the end
you can say more topics why because it
depends
kardashian yeah get it down looking at
this my skin looks too
brown too pale too blotchy in my bikini
it's not how i want my fans to see me
my personal assistant made an error
uploaded it on instagram it's not clever
no fellas wanna look at me more i gotta
take it down yes i implore
mca that's the copyright agreement 99
years
old and the queen is grieving going to
westminster abbey and lyon state
saying oh philip why do you have to go
away now it's me and my corg is on our
own
here in our buckingham palace palatial
home
he used to be here so he could say this
no
visiting the countries being racist
still he supported a lot
of charities was given to me
oh yeah i'll say it keep a straight face
no grin and say no
clara don't do heroin have you seen
train spotting it's a massive
error he's got a climb in a toilet he's
an addicted fella that's you and
mcgregor
playing a character called renton just
listen now
pay attention heroin is really bad
one don't chase the dragon and you know
it drags on for 20 more years
gonna have the planet and then it
collapses no longer democratic
the cia and the fbi put out a report and
said
we're all going to die no democracy in
the middle east
and no more pollution and the rising
seas we're going to go
so disgusted and so wet say it again
napoleon here we get a friendship with a
six-year-old girl on saint helena
he was on elba but he wouldn't stay
there he's like oh ribby
what am i going to do be on average
height and start
waterloo and then lose to the duke of
wellington
oh he wanted to be emperor and telling
his friends hello pope let me put the
crown on my own head
guillotine slicing off many people's
heads i know that wasn't him it just
happened in the same country amazon
union
yes jeff bezos confronts me and says hey
chris i'm a really rich man but i don't
like all these unionization plans all
the man down in bessemer
oh don't understand it there there the
warehouse they have gotta hand it to
them
does he sound like this is this his
accent i don't know jeff bezos yeah
he attacks it union busting not trusting
all the unions he says hey come on guys
why are you choosing to pay all of the
jews and not spend it on things you like
brazil oh yeah let me go and take a hike
like terry gilliam a psyllium direct in
brazil
but let me get a thing on top of a hill
call it sugarloaf mountain with
christ the redeemer but in a different
area or you should have seen their faces
when they came up with a plan and said
would make a slightly taller one of the
man
yeah it's done woohoo boom
thank you sorry for not i think i didn't
have clara turned up loud enough of my
headphones so i had to keep double
checking
uh excellent suggestion giving alice did
she do a good job yeah i don't
think you should do heroin okay that's
the consensus
let us know in the comments yeah i hate
to needle you about it hey
yeah it's not for hey guys if you are
struggling with heroin addiction then um
do
do get seek professional help yeah
that's what you've got to say in it yeah
you've got to say it if any if you've
been affected by any of the issues
raised in this podcast
please do call a professional exactly so
yeah
well lovely clara that's the end of the
show what a wonderful addition you were
thank you wonderful for having a bleak
bleak and depressing edition
but then you cheer this up by teaching
about demi lovato it's very true
yes um clara uh are you on social media
do you care for anyone to hunt you down
on there
i'm not on social media she's impossible
to find you she's a ghost
you cannot find clara b you can't find
alice um yes i'm on
instagram at let them eat books with
underscores instead of spaces and i am
also on instagram at chris turner comedy
and on youtube just search chris turner
um that is everything you've been
delightful clara's been delightful
alice winners always remains the but
delightful list the most delightful
thank you for listening
and goodbye